well hopeful optimists are suggesting
that the covet era may be followed by
the roaring 2020s
but in a new op-ed our next guest claims
rather than roaring
they'll be boring arguing quote the
future rolling out before us
is one not of greater freedom but of
endless pings
masks boosters and variants restrictions
meant to be limited
look as if they are going to be with us
for the duration people who like
government interference in their lives
might be happy author douglas murray is
here to explain it's a great piece in
the spectator
uh douglas so explain
uh good to be with you yes uh the yale
um uh
academic nick christakis said earlier
this year that it's possible that
after the krona era we would have a
booming decade
and that much as the spanish flew a
century ago was followed by the roaring
1920s
so the corona era would be followed by
the roaring 2020s
and i suggest i i think this is off i
think we're in for the boring 2020s
for endless regurgitations of the same
arguments
for the endless restrictions for the
endless judgmentalism of people who
don't go along with all the latest
restrictions
and actually that alongside some of the
economics you know the u.s has the
highest inflation it's had since 2008
suggests to me that this is going to be
a very tricky decade i
i wish it would raw yeah but i think
it's going to boar
yeah i think one of the trickiest parts
one of the saddest parts is that
this kind of mass surveillance that you
talk about in your piece this kind of
nanny state
is being so normalized by young people
who will be our next leaders we have a
story that we did today douglas on
medical schools are now denying
biological sex you can't say male you
can't say female
it's the students policing the
professors and the professors having to
apologize
how important is it in this moment um
when
when big government and woke in is woke
inc is forcing us
to you know parrot and repeat and
believe all these lies like you know
that there's no difference between male
and female for example or
any of the other lies we've heard
throughout this pandemic how important
is it for us to just tell the truth
oh it's vital there's nothing more
important i agree yes the
piece you referred to uh on barry
weiss's sub stack is
referred to a a medical school in
california
in which the lecturer stops during the
lecture and says
i'm so sorry that earlier on i said
pregnant women i didn't mean to imply by
that that only women can become pregnant
i meant
a woman who has become pregnant if you'd
been to this medical school i mean you
you'd end up stupider afterwards than
you were when you went in
uh you you'd leave medical school
believing that men can become pregnant
i mean this is an example of this this
craziness you know
china's eating america's lunch
economically
and america's top medical schools are
telling people that uh
men can become pregnant and much more so
the crucial thing that will always give
us the edge in america is
telling the truth as we see it and not
sticking to lies
yep it's that simple thank you douglas
murray you're always refreshing to hear
from